If you don't have a deal and you're in the middle of like trying to,
you got somebody hooked and you're trying to close a deal. Now I'm asking Jeff,
what would be your recommendations there?
Right. Yeah. I think your first one about if you have a BO,
just let them know and talk to them. That's the best thing. I've gone over this.
I believe it was in the, the last live that I did,
where you can start manipulating some of the keyword themes,
because some of them are going to be more expensive than others. And so some,
you know, the keyword themes are all really broad matched.
And so what you may find, if you go back through your,
your research and your due diligence, you might find certain,
like a volume of keywords with a lower CPC versus a higher
volume with the highest CPC.
And you can start manipulating and maybe removing a keyword theme or two and
hitting refresh and see if that gets your budget lower so that you can still
kind of get some leads coming in while you're trying to get someone on the hook
and someone or why you're, you know,
why you're trying to get that business owner on a hook and land a deal.
So that's definitely a way you can try to stay in a market,
but just remember like up here, like this is now not a thousand dollar a month
deal.
This might be a $2,000 a month deal because I want to turn the ads back on for
the bigger CPC, but that's definitely a technique.
Several of you that I've helped out in the last couple of weeks, that's,
that's been, that's been very helpful.
And you've been able to keep getting ads and you've been able to stay, you know,
18 to 23, $24 a day in a market that if you were going for the main
keyword, you're looking at like almost $40 a day.
So that that's how I would get around it. It's a little,
I know it's confusing to say here, but the last live that I did,
where we recorded it, I demonstrated how to do that.